in the last video we saw that if you
took some solid zinc and stuck it in a
solution of copper sulfate that the zinc
will essentially give electrons to the
copper so then you have zinc
cations that are in the solution so
essentially it'll become a solution of
zinc sulfate and the copper once it gets
those two electrons is going to go into
its neutral it's solid state it's going
to precipitate out of the solution and
we saw the reaction right over here
solid zinc plus copper sulfate in
solution in water it's an aqueous
solution you have the copper the solid
copper precipitating out and now it's a
solution of zinc sulfate that the zinc
has essentially been oxidized it gave it
lost to electrons it went from neutral
to positive and the copper went from
positive to neutral so the copper took
those two electrons zinc was oxidized by
copper it lost electrons to the copper
copper was reduced by zinc its charge
was reduced by zinc it gained electrons
from zinc now this by itself is
interesting it's an interesting redox
reaction something was oxidized
something was reduced but wouldn't it be
interesting is if we could somehow
somewhat separate these two half
reactions and make and make these
electrons travel over a wire
now why would that be interesting to
make electrons travel over a wire well
if electrons traveling over a wire
that's a current and you can make
current do useful things like power a
motor or a light or whatever it might be
and so essentially if we can do that we
would have constructed something of a
battery if we can keep that going if we
can keep the current flowing we would
have cons constructed something like a
battery and what i have here this is a
picture of a galvanic sometimes called a
voltaic cell and this is doing exactly
that it's it's separating these two half
reactions and separating them with a
wire so zinc can give copper its
electrons but it forces the electrons to
go along this wire and produce an actual
current
so let's think about why this is working
so you have
you have solid zinc right over here
we've already said that look you know
the solid zinc wouldn't mind giving its
electrons to copper copper wouldn't mind
taking it copper is more electronegative
and so
you have a reality
where the solid zinc
could give away its two electrons
and become the cation zinc so a positive
charge and then it dissolves in the
water once it has a positive charge it's
it's easy to dissolve into a polar
solvent like water
and then you have those two electrons
where those two electrons gonna go those
two electrons can then
those two electrons can then go and be
given to the copper
can then be given to the copper and both
zinc and copper are great conductors of
electricity they're transition metals
they have the seas of electrons so
electrons can travel with it within them
fairly easily and so you have your two
electrons so those are your two
electrons that i showed traveling in
green and they can come all the way to
the bottom of where this where this
copper where this copper
bar is in contact with the copper with
the copper sulfate solution and now
you're going to have some
you're going to have an atom
a cation i should say an ion of copper
that when it comes in contact with those
electrons it's going to nab them up it's
going to nab them up and become neutral
so it's going to nab them up and become
neutral and when it becomes neutral it's
going to precipitate out of the solution
it's going to precipitate on to that bar
now you might be saying look if more and
more positive things if more and more of
this zinc
this positive zinc is flowing in this
wouldn't this make this an imbalance and
if this solution becomes too positive
then the electrons wouldn't want to
leave as much anymore so if you just
have a bunch of
if this starts becoming very very very
very positive and similarly if all of
the positive stuff all the copper if all
of the copper cations are are capturing
the electrons the solution is going to
become more and more negative it's going
to have more sulfate and less of this of
and less of the the positively charged
copper ions so what can we do to make
sure that that doesn't happen too
quickly
well what we do is we produce something
we use something called a salt bridge
and this salt bridge right over here
salt
salt bridge this helps equalize this
helps neutralize that effect that we
just talked about and with a salt bridge
you can kind of view it it's not just
it's not going to be liquid because then
everything inside of it would just would
just fall out you can kind of view it as
a goo
of a salt and this one in this in this
diagram we picked sodium sulfate as our
as our as our salt so for every sulfate
molecule you have sulfate anion you have
two sodium two sodium cations and so
what's going to naturally what's going
to naturally happen here
well as this becomes more and more
positively charged as more and more
positive positive zinc ions go into the
solution the negative sulfate ions are
going to want to come out of here
so the negative sulfate ions are going
to want to go
are going to want to leave the all of
its their negative friends right over
here
go into the salt bridge and the ones
that are already in the salt bridge are
going to want to come out out here
similarly the sodium the sodium right
over here
will be tempted to help neutralize the
sodium could go in this direct let me do
it this way could go
could go in this direction and help
neutralize any net negativity that's
happening there and so that will keep
each of these solutions from becoming
too positive
or too negative and allow this current
to continue to flow and do useful things